when actors have a relationship off
camera it can make things awkward on
camera which the stars of a certain
lowbudget '90s movie know better than
anybody and that's not the only time
cinematic love scenes have gotten
majorly
uncomfortable love scenes aren't just
for romantic comedies they can appear in
all sorts of movies even the most
serious of serious dramas quite frankly
audiences can often be in the mood for
some kind of romantic interlude just to
break the tension then again just
because a movie can have a love scene
doesn't mean that it should case in
point the 20 5 historical drama Munich
if there's any movie that doesn't need a
steamy encounter it's almost certainly
one about Israeli assassins sent to
avenge the deaths of athletes who were
killed by terrorists at the 1972 Summer
Olympics after spending a very long time
hunting down terrorists anner played by
Eric Bana has sex with his wife the
action Cuts between their wild ecstasy
and violent images of people being
gunned down at an airport to be fair
director Steven Spielberg was probably
just trying to be both Artful and
cathartic with this scene and after
after all it's not like intercutting sex
with violence hasn't been done before
but that doesn't make it any less
uncomfortable in this case after three
movies about an evil doll possessed by
the soul of a serial killer the team
behind the child's play franchise needed
to expand their universe and so they
decided to have Chucky take a lover
1998's Bride of Chucky finds the titular
killer doll reconnecting with Tiffany
his girlfriend from his time as a human
after he kills her he then transfers her
soul into the body of a bride doll that
looks like a blonde female version of
himself self a bloody crime scene from
these two Psychopaths follows and that
isn't exactly a good environment for a
love scene but this moment was always
going to be strange and uncomfortable as
it involves the most intimate acts
rendered with the best technology and
puppetry that a mid-budget '90s movie
had to offer after Chucky proposes
marriage Amorous feelings quickly take
over there's a lot of loud open-mouth
kissing from two characters whose mouths
don't really move as well as stripping
in front of a roaring fire and the two
dolls doing the deed in a silhouette
that leaves a little to the imagination
making things even more unbearable are
all the cheesy Wise Cracks I am
anatomically correct you
know few films have received the level
of critical derision and simultaneous
fanic claim suffered by 50 Shades of
Gray that's probably because most of the
people who like the movie are also fans
of the novels that feature infamously
corny sentences like my inner goddess is
doing the mor with some salsa moves so
it's no surprise then that the movie
version presented the same heavy-handed
implausible romance that sees mousy
virgin Anastasia steel transformed into
a kinky submissive at the hands of
Christian Gray each love scene escalates
further and further into Ridiculousness
to the point that the climax of the film
occurs when Anastasia freaks out after
Christian Spanx are too hard this
happens in his so-called playroom which
features hooks whips chains and all
manner of medieval looking torture
devices that Anastasia seemingly has no
issue with
stop
no the 2009 sci-fi horror movie splice
raises a lot of questions about the
moral implications and personal
ramifications of science particularly
the rapidly evolving discipline of
genetic engineering while working at a
scientific facility called nucleic
exchange research and development
genetic Engineers Clive and Elsa played
by Adrien Brody and Sarah PA develop a
viable creature by mixing human DNA with
genetic materials from animals Elsa
names this creature dren which is nerd
backwards and then she grows from a
child to a young woman very quickly CL
clearly finds dren to be very beautiful
although she's more animal than human
with her Giant Eyes long tail and feet
that look like cans it's obvious that
we're building to some kind of intimate
act between Clive and dran but that
doesn't make it any less weird when it
happens and it does indeed happen in a
barn where dren has been locked up no
less it's basically like Clive is
getting busy with his coworker and his
pet all at once mcgruber began as a
recurring bit on Saturday Night Live
that parody the action adventure TV show
mcgyver which starred Richard Dean
Anderson is a genius who could save the
day by making life-saving inventions out
of household materials but in the SNL
version Will Forte plays mcgruber as a
supposed genius who would try to do the
same thing but inevitably always fail
explosively when mcgruber became a movie
in 2010 it needed to be fleshed out
significantly for a featurelength
running time so it wound up as a parody
of over the- top 80s action movies
amidst all the explosions and Lone Wolf
theatrics those films usually also
include a steamy love scene and so does
mcgruber as Mr mr's power ballad Broken
Wings plays mcgruber begins to make
sweet love to his wife Casey in her
wedding gown but then things get
hilariously weird and dark the music
Falls away and viewers see a bare
bottomed mcgruber grunting away in a
graveyard while a groundskeeper watches
Casey actually died earlier in the movie
which is reestablished with a cut back
to mcgruber who's now standing nude in a
graveyard at night moaning and talking
dirty to a ghost that nobody else can
see just tell me what you want met the
twisty 2003 career and Thriller old boy
from writer director Park Chen wuk won
numerous Awards on the festival circuit
and eventually became an international
cult favorite it's not only one of the
most acclaimed South Korean films ever
made it also helped put the Country
Cinema on the map without old boy
parasite may never have become an Oscar
winning phenomenon in the midst of the
twisty and unpredictable plot there's a
love scene that becomes disturbing in
retrospect after all the Mysteries have
fully unraveled in the opening scenes
the protagonist odesu is arrested one
night for public drunkenness which
causes him to is his young daughter's
birthday party after a friend retrieves
him from the police station he's
kidnapped and isolated in a hotel room
for 15 years when he's finally released
he wanders into a sushi restaurant and
Strikes up a relationship with young
Chef Mido he tries to get his life back
together though he gives up on finding
his daughter when he learns that she was
adopted by a Swedish couple then his
captor Leu Jin contacts des and gives
him an ultimatum if he guesses the
reason for his imprisonment within 5
days Wu Jin will kill himself if not
he'll kill me do des and mido's
relationship grows increasingly intimate
and Desu soon figures it all out he went
to high school with wuin and he saw him
engage an incest with his sister Des
spread the news and the sister was so
mortified that she killed herself it
would seem that Wu Jin has had his
revenge on Des with the yearslong
imprisonment but as it turns out his
plan was even more Sinister than that as
the climactic scene revealed that des's
long lost daughter is actually
Meo before he became an Oscar winner for
greenbook Peter and his brother Bobby
made some of the most outrageous
comedies of the 9s Like There's
Something About Mary Dumb and Dumber and
Kingpin that last one Stars Woody
harelson is down on his luck former
bowling Champion Roy mson an attempt to
hustle amateur Bowlers goes poorly and
he loses his hand in a ball return
accident two decades later he's reduced
to selling bowling supplies and spending
most of his time drinking he has little
choice but to get in bed with his landl
played by frequent fairly collaborator
Lyn Shay so that she'll be more
forgiving with his perpetually late rent
payments that that's the uncomfortable
setup a man who suffers from excessive
drinking use has to prostitute himself
to avoid becoming homeless there's an
even more unsettling payoff Roy stages
an attack on the land lady so as to
chase the guy off and earn himself some
favor but she finds out about it and
then forces him to make it up to her in
the bedroom then it cuts to her lying in
bed smoking a cigarette in post coal
Bliss while Roy throws up in the
adjoining bathroom you still owe me
another month's rent almost any love
scene in a comedy can make this list as
they're usually played for awkward
laughs but 2009's Observe and Report
isn't your standard comedy it's a dark
and twisted flick written and directed
by jod Hill the creator of the HBO
series Eastbound and D when m security
officer Ronnie played by Seth Rogan
finally LS his dream girl Brandy played
by Anna Ferris their romantic encounter
is rather seedy they're both drunk which
already means that they're not thinking
straight and can't give informed consent
nevertheless they go back to her place
for sex even though Brandy has ingested
a lot of kenaz aam and is only
semiconscious Observe and Report tries
to recover the scene with a joke as the
past out Brandy wakes up and asks Ronnie
why he's stopping but at that point the
creepiness is just too much and we're
witnessing a gross exploitation of a
terrible situation although considering
how dark this movie is that may have
been intentional the 1995 erotic
Thriller show Girls came hot on the
heels of director Paul ver hovind's
iconic run of Robocop Total Recall and
Basic Instinct so he was probably
looking for a similarly viseral response
when he took on the world of showgirl
dancers in Las Vegas unfortunately he
made a film that's had a rock reception
at best some critics cited its campy
melodrama as a detraction and sure if
you're not on the film's unusual
wavelength it may feel like something
that would be more at home on Lifetime
if not for the graphic sex particularly
the infamous po scene Elizabeth Berkeley
plays the lead character of Nomi Malone
who rides around on top of Kyle
McLaughlin like someone just threw a
toaster into the water if you can manage
to wipe away your tears of laughter you
can literally see all the stunt
confusion written all over his face but
ver hovind's reputation has endured
Beyond shog girl girls and the film
itself has since been rediscovered and
re-evaluated by a new generation of
audiences and critics it doesn't suck
1997's kickboxing academy was also
released under the far more boring if
accurate title teen boxer the plot
naturally enough concerns the day-to-day
activities at a kickboxing academy
ultimately the kids at the Academy have
to square off against the kids from
another martial arts school among those
kickboxing kids are a couple of
fresh-faced teenagers named Cindy and
Dany they're played by Kyler Lee years
before she starred in Not Another Teen
Movie in G's anatomy and Christopher
commonly who's probably best known for
multiple Power Ranger series in real
life the two of them are brother and
sister which makes the fact that their
characters are romantically involved the
height of awkwardness and the people
making kickboxing academy apparently
didn't think it was too weird to include
multiple scenes in which Cindy and Dany
passionately kiss each other at the end
of 2000's requim for a dream each of the
main characters are deep in the worst
chapters of their addictions Jennifer
Connelly plays Maran a heroin addict who
resorts to selling her body for the drug
when she's recruited into doing a show
for a bunch of salivating men who Jer
and throw money at her and another woman
to be fair this isn't so much a love
scene as it is a horrifically graphic
act that occurs amid a swirling
brilliantly edited sequence that weaves
together the alha predicaments that each
character has found themselves in on top
of that it also imparts their panic and
despair onto the audience through a
jarringly effective use of shock
value